just such a treat to be back I spend
many hours on that side of the room so
it's wild to be on this side of the room
and going whoa there was actually like
monitors up here like that's how the the
speakers kept track of where in their
talks they were
um so that's good to know
um and this is sort of the first set of
talks I've given since the pandemic and
so I thought it was a a really great
opportunity to talk about some new ideas
that have been on my mind and
particularly with you know all of you is
my captive audience I thought that I
would use this talk as an opportunity to
think out loud about what the role of
HCI should be in the face of all of this
really incredible rapid progress that Ai
and ml have made particularly kind of
scoped in the last uh you know six
months or so
um and and sort of as I was trying to
think about what uh you know the role of
HCI should be I was reminded of this
figure from Jonathan Gruden's 2009
article in triple AI about how Ai and
HCI are two fields that are divided by a
common Focus right and as you can see in
moments where AI makes a lot of progress
right it's it's almost like the pendulum
swings towards ever increased amounts of
automation right perhaps at the expense
of more hcisque approaches of human
intelligence augmentation or
amplification but also I think HCI is in
a more established stronger position
than it's ever been in the past and so
you know I really think uh you know it's
it's uh you know our responsibility to
to think about what that counterbalance
to ever increased automation should be
and so I I often like you know in
moments like this like to sort of turn
to history and and ground myself and so
if we cast back to the first AI winter
with Southern sketchpad right around
that time you know there was this
foundational paper written by lick
lighter at MIT titled man computer
symbiosis and I think the gendering is
unfortunate and unfortunately reflective
of the times but nevertheless in this
paper lick lighter put forth this really
compelling Vision about uh you know the
ways in which a computer could interact
with us through this intuitive guided
trial and error procedure turning up
Solutions
um and revealing you know unexpected
turns in the reasoning and I was really
tempted to put this sort of side by side
with this very recent demo that openai
released with Chad GPT plus plugins
where you can you know upload this
music.csv data set and then start to
have this very natural language
interaction to ask what are the columns
in the data set how many rows in there
in the data set and then even say you
know can you give me some basic
visualizations of this data set and you
know it thinks a little bit it's working
real hard and there you go like it
produces sort of three visualizations
and even starts to give you maybe
something that looks like an explanation
and I wonder you know is it time to roll
out our mission accomplished banners
right like have we achieved lick
lighter's Vision to think in interaction
with a computer in the same way that we
think with a colleague whose competence
supplements our own now
I don't think it's time to roll out the
mission accomplished banners right but
I'm hopeful that the reason it's not
that is not just my sort of you know
hope that we haven't been put out of
jobs
um but rather that there is something
more to do so two years after lick
lighters man computer symbiosis Douglas
engelbart
um you know wrote up this really
incredible framework called augmenting
human intellect and right in the
introduction of this piece
um we already start to see how engelbart
you know is defining a much more
expansive role of human augmentation so
the idea is not just about problem
solving right which he does mention
right at the end there right to derive
solutions to a problem but it's also
about using computers to help us think
right it's to to increase the capacity
uh increase our capacity to approach a
complex problem situation to gain
comprehension right really about this
thinking and not just the problem
solving pieces
um and really what I like is how he
thinks we'll get there certainly there
will be sophisticated methods
high-powered electronic AIDS but to me
the part that really resonates in in his
prescription here is streamline
terminology and notation and that's
going to be a theme of my talk here
certainly one of the themes that
underlies my group's work and so in
contrast to that chat GPT demo a few
years ago I had the pleasure to work
with some collaborators at Berkeley ifan
Wu and Joe hellerstein who you see in
the top right hand corner on the system
called B2 so this is a Jupiter notebook
it's a very commonly used data science
environment where people can start to
write code in the style of a python
reple but what B2 does is saying well in
addition to that sort of linear style of
data science analysis and programming
there's a lot of value in a more visual
analysis dashboard style interface like
Tableau and so what B2 tries to do is
bring these two pieces together so you
can see once I've invoked B2 it adds the
this on the sidebar
and I can start to issue regular sort of
python you know pandas commands like
looking at the data frame getting a you
know a sense of how many rows there are
what the columns are and now we can
start to write some code to do a little
bit of data transformation and
visualization notice here in all of
these steps you know when I'm authoring
a visualization I don't have to specify
what that visualization should look like
right I'm just calling these dot Vis
methods on the data frame and B2 behind
the scenes is figuring out what sort of
visualization actually makes sense based
on the history of the the
Transformations that were performed on
the the data frame so in the case of
year for instance if I've grouped by
year the most sensible visualization to
produce is a histogram of the the number
of counts of data records across years
you might have also noticed in the video
that if I click the fields on the the
right hand side there that it
automatically produces an equivalent
visualization but it doesn't stop there
it adds you know the code and tags them
with these little you know yellow emojis
to indicate that there's actually sort
of a common shared representation here
right clicking on uh the sidebar not
only produces the visualization but
produces the equivalent code as well and
what's interesting is that these
visualizations aren't just output
mechanisms systems but I can start to
interact with them to sort of do this
cross filtering interaction so all the
other bars update to reflect the data
shown in the highlighted bars and B2 is
keeping this as an interaction log that
is semantically Meaningful to me so this
interaction log doesn't comprise Mouse
clicks and keystrokes and things like
that but it's expressing data queries
right which states have been selected
and I can use that data query to perform
subsequent sort of analyzes based on my
interactive results so I can say great
I'm gonna you know copy some code to the
clipboard paste it in as a data query to
look at what the interactive selection
should be and then you know proceed with
some other sort of visual analysis
and so as we're sort of you know looking
at these two forms of interaction I was
trying to figure out well some things
feel the same right I've got that kind
of conversational back and forth I'm
sure on the left hand side which had GPT
it's a more natural language
conversation on the right hand side it's
more of a rebel conversation but also
things feel qualitatively different and
how do I actually kind of characterize
what is the same and what is the
difference and I thought really hard
about it and I realized that actually
maybe what still matters is direct
manipulation
right and by direct manipulation I don't
mean
um just the sort of Ben Schneiderman
version of the term which is you know
associated with graphical user
interfaces and and having a
representation on screen that you can
manipulate and undo redo and things like
that but what I mean here is the deeper
treatment of direct manipulation that
three cognitive scientists Ed Hutchins
Jim Holland and Don Norman wrote in
about the mid-1980s so in particular in
Hutchins at all's treatment of direct
manipulation they sort of um you know
imagine direct manipulation to be this
cognitive process between a user's goals
and the user interface
and you know they identify this gulf of
execution that exists when a user has to
translate their goals into commands that
they execute on the user interface and
similarly a return Gulf of evaluation
when a user has to figure out well did
the UI do the thing that I was expecting
it to do right I'm seeing a lot of nods
in the audience because you know if
you've had experience in user
interaction design user experience
you've maybe experienced these terms
Gulf of evaluation and execution but
what I find interesting in this 1985
paper is that they went one level deeper
so in particular they identified this
idea of a semantic distance which is
basically how users take the fuzzy
Notions in their head and translate
those into the nouns and verbs of the
user interface right so going doing that
sort of sense meaning operation of
transforming your intentions into the
particular actions that might exist in
the user interface face
and in addition to the semantic distance
they identified what I what I love I
love this term and articulatory distance
right so it's not necessarily the
meaning that we care about anymore but
the way in which we're conveying that
meaning through the UI and this is
particularly important because you might
have several user interfaces that all
express the same semantics right you can
conduct the same set of in uh you know
operations with them the same nouns and
verbs but the way you do that might be
different because one interface might be
graphical the other one might be textual
another one might be conversational
gesture oriented Etc and their claim in
this paper was that that articulation
the form of that meaning is is really
really important um just as important as
the semantics and of course these
distances exist on the Gulf of
evaluation as well so the articulatory
distances how do I perceive the changes
that occurred in the UI and start to
bring meaning to that that perception
that perceptual operation and by
interpreting and evaluating the degree
to which they met my goals so this is
actually going to give us the kind of
conceptual machinery for the rest of the
talk and it's a little bit dense and so
I want to return to sort of the prior
two examples and think about how they
manifest these two kinds of distances so
in the case of the chat GPT example you
know if we start with semantic distance
I would say that well the semantics
aren't really well defined right they're
not really explicit because what these
models have done is they've learned over
you know vast corpuses of text often
just text that is present on the
internet and so what they've learned is
this latent space that is very ambiguous
in the semantics that are encoded in
that latent space so as a user it's hard
for me to know how to translate my
intentions into something that the
system can understand because I don't
know what it is the system knows about
the world but as I'm sure many of us are
aware like prompt engineering is a thing
right so if I figure out exactly how to
craft my you know natural language
expression suddenly I can get the model
to very rapidly almost zero shot adopt
the semantics that I want and that feels
like a very powerful
um you know affordance that we've not
necessarily had before
on the other side you know the semantic
distance in in the Jupiter notebook in
B2 had explicitly defined semantics
right we had the explicit semantics of
pandas on the data frame of the
visualization library of being able to
click on the fields in a graphical user
interface to produce visualizations and
every time I did that I had the shared
representation of the code so either I
would off of the code and it would
produce a visualization or if the system
produced some code I could go in and
comment an uncomment entries or tweak
the code in a particular way and things
like that and so it gave me the shared
representation that allowed me to bridge
between input and output mechanisms
really really easily
with articulatory distance in chat GPT
right natural language it's been
enormously powerful because it's reduced
the sort of learning threshold for a lot
of things right so if I don't know
exactly what it is I want or how to sort
of pose it to the question I can lean
into the ambiguity of natural language
and chat GPT catches up to my intentions
pretty rapidly which is great but
conversely sometimes I know exactly what
it is I want and it's really frustrating
to have to express precise operations
through the ambiguity of natural
language
and then as a result because of the fact
that natural language is the only
mechanism so far by which we can
interact with many of these models
there's a disconnect if your output is
visual like the case of visualization so
I can't interact with the visualizations
in any way to do subsequent back and
forth interactions with the model now I
don't think the second point is sort of
a fundamental limitation but it's
certainly you know the state of where we
are today
and on the other hand with with um you
know Jupiter notebook and B2 with the
articulatory distance we've got
basically the inverse of this right
we've got a nice precise programmatic
syntax so if I know that syntax I can
work really really efficiently right a
sort of a common affordance of many sort
of command line style interfaces but I
really need to learn that syntax to be
effective and and in some cases with
poorly designed syntaxes which I might
maybe argue pandas is is an example of
right I constantly have to look up the
documentation for right there's a
learning curve associated with it that
slows people down
yeah Michael my question I usually
thought of
the thought of the learning curve of a
formal language as a semantic distance
rather than an articulatory distance
rather the articulatory is like how hard
is it to construct the theory once I
understand yeah so the reason I put it I
think this is a great question you know
what what lies in semantic and
articulatory and and oftentimes it is
quite a fuzzy distinction the reason I
put this in articulatory is my
experience with pandas oftentimes is I
know what it is I want to do right I
know the sort of operation I want to
perform on my on my data frame I just
don't know the specific syntax that I
need to look up exactly exactly
um but certainly you know if if you
don't know what it is you want to do
then the affordances of natural language
absolutely help because you can kind of
you know pose things in really um fuzzy
ways and and kind of iterate towards
your outcome
um and and I think you see some of this
ambiguity in in sort of you know the
distinction between semantic and
articulatory distance here with this
this last point where because there are
consistent semantics that actually has
this knock-on effect on the articulation
because now there's a shared
representation of input and output and
that simplifies that articulatory
distance as well so there's not quite
that disconnect that we see on the
Chachi BT side
and so you know that's a that's you know
I found semantic and articulatory
distances to be a really helpful uh sort
of uh framework and I wanted to use it
to sort of analyze the very last step
um in the output that that demo produced
so it it you know it's basically this
this thing that masquerays is an
explanation of the visualizations that
chat GPT produced but if you actually
look at what it says right here's some
basic visualizations number one a
histogram of song durations colon this
shows the distribution of song durations
in seconds all right fair enough uh
scatter plot of song hotness versus
artist familiarity this shows the
relationship between song hotness and
artist familiarity well I would hope so
um and then bar chart of the top 10 most
frequent artist names this shows the top
10 most frequent artist names in the
data set right these are not really
explanations but
they're pretty provocative or evocative
in the potential that these models might
have and allowing us to produce these
textual descriptions of visual artifacts
and certainly you know a lot of of
people certainly lots of big tech
companies have thought about the ways in
which you could use all kinds of machine
learning models not just llms to do the
sort of Rich description of visual
content and particularly for this sort
of these accessibility use cases like
how do you describe these kinds of of
artifacts to people who are blind or
have low vision and lots of people have
studied the degree to which these models
are effective and found maybe
unsurprisingly that they're not terribly
effective right now right so here is a
quote from a participant from one of our
studies who says you know the reader
wouldn't get much Insight from text like
this which not only you know is
problematic because it doesn't
effectively convey information but more
troublingly it actually increases the
burden that readers face when they're
trying to make sense of this output
right there's a lot of sort of noise
that gets added to that experience
another participant you know says very
very interestingly the problem with
these textual descriptions is also that
it it robs me of control of consuming
the data right a participant another
participants said I want to have the
time and space to interpret the numbers
for myself before I read any kind of
textual description that does the
analysis for me
um and so to me these sound very similar
to issues associated with a semantic and
articulatory distance right that first
quote talking about well these texts
aren't conveying anything interesting
um the second set talking about well I
want to have that time and space I want
to be able to control the form with
which that text is conveyed to me and so
I want to dig into how we might address
these two distances in the case of
accessibility but before I do that I
want to give us a sense of how people
who are blind or have low vision
experience
um you know the the inner the internet
and in graphical interfaces today so I'm
going to turn things over to my PhD
student Jonathan Zhong who will give us
a quick demo of an assistive technology
called a screen reader that basically
narrates on-screen content
selected by the cursor will be read out
as text-to-speech so here I can
demonstrate what the accessible HTML
version of our paper looks like to a
streamer reader
so as you can see what a screen reader
does is it basically sort of linearizes
the operation of of you know reading
perceiving understanding graphical
content on on
um a user interface and in particular
you might notice that the narration was
actually quite rapid right and this is
actually a slowed down version of what
um you know proficient screen meter
users use which is often much much
faster but what is interesting about the
screen reader use case is that it forces
that linearity right and the key
challenge in figuring out the
articulatory distance in the case of
accessibilities how do you take
visualizations that probably all of us
in the audience have slightly subtly
different ways of reading right maybe
some of you start by reading the title
then moving to the axes then looking at
you know the shapes While others might
start by looking at the most Salient
Trend and then start to you know map out
to what the axes and and legends and
stuff like that are how do we take all
of that rich diversity but linearize it
so the people who use screen readers can
nevertheless have that same you know
choice in needing a visualization but
under under these conditions and so the
way we have chosen to do that is
basically by restructuring the content
of a visualization into a text oriented
hierarchy so at the top at the root of
this hierarchy is just a summary of the
chart probably the trends that are shown
in the chart and then the hierarchy
branches off into the individual sort of
data fields or the encodings in this
case right the x-axis the y-axis The
Legend and things like that and then
people can start to drill down in ways
that maintain some correspondence with
the visual artifact so one step below
you know the x-axis is stepping through
them by the major ticks right one step
below the major ticks would be minor
ticks and then ultimately you would get
to the individual data points so let me
throw things back to Jonathan to give us
a demo of how this works
the scatter plot of penguin data and to
a screen reader our system represents
this scatter plot as a keyboard
navigable data structure that contains
text descriptions at varying levels of
detail
so when a screen reader user first
Encounters this visualization on a page
they'll be able to read off a high level
alt text description of what the chart
is so penguins
and if they're interested in getting
more detail about this visualization
they can dive in by pressing the down
arrow key to descend one level in the
hierarchy and access descriptions about
the different encodings of the scatter
plot so I'm going to press the down
arrow key accessible
values 170 to 240. I can press the left
and right arrow keys to flip through
descriptions of the other axes and
legends watch the title body mass G for
linear scale with values from 2500 to
6500 Legend titled species for common
with three values Gen 2 review
cool so let's say I am interested in
getting more information about the
x-axis I can use the left Arrow key to
navigate back to the x-axis description
and then press down one more time to
descend a level of detail into the
x-axis
title x-axis titled flipper light and
then for the range 220 230 35 values in
the interval
so on this level underneath the x-axis
uh I'm accessing descriptions of
intervals along the x-axis and it's
reading out to me how many data values
are contained within each interval so by
pressing left and right I can kind of
get a sense of the distribution of data
along the x-axis rain to rain too hot
rain 190 rain won't rain 170 rain rain
190 200 150 day values in the interval
so let's say I am interested in this
range from 190 to 200 I can then press
down arrow again to dive into the
individual data points that are
contained within this interval 113
flicker length 190 body mass G 3650
species badly two of 113 Flip 3 of 113
for 113.5 113.
so let's say that instead of moving up
and down this hierarchical structure I
would rather just move around the XY
Grid in the scatter plot as if I were
kind of feeling around a a tactile
graphic for example
I can start by navigating over to the
grid view of the scatter plot attack
Legend titles preview of scatter plot
70 values in the interval body mass and
once I descend into this part of the
hierarchy I can use the wasd keys to
move up and down different squares along
the grid G
and so similarly to before it's starting
off by giving me the number of data
values that are contained in that square
so that I can get a sense of the
distribution of the data
and so we designed this in collaboration
with a blind HCI uh researcher named
Daniel Hodges and this was the first
time he felt like he actually understood
and and could you know build a mental
model of what it was that a scatter plot
was representing we saw these sorts of
comments reflected in user studies that
we ran about how you know the form of
this textual output really influenced
participants mental model of what the
data was what the trends were and things
like that so one participant for
instance said you know I now know how to
drill down and up between different
layers in the data to get get an overall
picture and it gives me a different way
of thinking and another one said you
know I'm thinking more in spatial terms
because this is just a new method for
navigating and moving through the the
grid and drilling down to information
and things like that and so you know
what's what I find interesting here is
that at every step right the cement into
content stayed exactly the same right
and there wasn't even very rich semantic
content it was a range and then a count
of the data values all we manipulated
was that articulation that form right
giving it a hierarchical nature adding
all of these different navigational
affordances and just manipulating the
articulation had this huge impact on
people's mental models of the data and I
think that we're really sort of just at
the tip of the iceberg of these sort of
more accessible structures currently in
my group are thinking about just you
know the impact that token order has on
how people using screen mirrors build up
those mental models right if you're
constantly prompting them with the range
first rather than the actual data values
does that introduce friction to their
capacity to build that mental model and
things like that but in all of this you
know where is semantic distance right
like how do we actually start to make
that textual descriptions more
interesting and meaningful and this is
where I think LM items can really help
us right for one reason it's because
there's just a sheer amount of textual
content we need to be able to produce
that is infeasible to expect a human to
sort of manually author but there are
other sort of implications that we'll
touch upon really shortly but before we
can get llms to actually sort of produce
the content we want what we need to do
is shift from that very latent space
with implicit semantics to a set of
explicit semantics right we need to
impose a conceptual model onto our llms
or another way of saying that is we need
to get the LMS to understand what a good
textual description of a visualization
is
and so that's what my then PhD student
Alan lundgaard set out to do we ran a
crowdsourced study where we got sort of
2 000 descriptions of of
um you know uh charts and through
qualitative coding we realized there are
basically four kinds of semantic content
that textual description should convey
the first most primitive layer is
basically just the sort of construction
details of the chart right what are the
titles the labels the scales the units
Etc and you know accessibility best
practices say that this is some of the
most important content to convey because
it gives people sort of important
milestones and landmarks one level above
that are the sort of statistical
properties like minimum maximum you know
outliers and things like that and then
one level above that is is probably what
is cited people we consider the real
value of visualization to be right the
perceptual and cognitive characteristics
like complex Trends and patterns things
that you know automated statistical
methods we typically think of as not
being sufficient at and then finally the
fourth and highest level are what
journalists often consider to be the
real value of visualization which is the
narration that gets associated with it
right what is the data story that you're
able to tell through the visualization
can you explain what you're seeing the
causal mechanisms etc etc now another
reason I think llms are really suited
for this sort of semantic bridging task
is because when we asked cited and blind
people what their preferences were when
it came to these four layers of four
levels we saw really distinct uh
preferences in the case of sighted
people right because we've got our own
visual perception doing that sort of uh
you know bridging of the Gulf of
evaluation cited people tended to want
higher and higher levels of content
being conveyed through text blind
readers on the other hand were pretty
significantly diversioned right for many
of them they didn't want those level
three and four particularly the level
four captions at all because they wanted
that time and space to to do the
interpretation for themselves and so
here this this you know visualization to
me conveys the you know llms can help us
or our machine learning models can help
us think about sort of personalizing the
semantics of a user interface in a way
that maybe we haven't had the
opportunity to study so far right
there's been a lot of work and
personalization but it's often been at
that level of the articulation right
changing the sizes of buttons and
adapting color palettes and things like
that and there's maybe an opportunity
now to use llms to actually change what
the nouns the the verbs the you know the
concepts of a user interface are much
more fundamentally and so the way we're
going about doing this in the case of
textual descriptions is we're going to
be releasing very soon a data set of
about you know actually now we're over
12 000 pairs of chart captions and we've
generated some of these captions and
we've crowdsourced some of these
captions and we started to train
Baseline models to do this task and one
of the interesting features here is how
do we represent the semantics of a chart
to a large language model right one way
could just be let's treat the chart as
an image right this is just a set of
pixels and unsurprisingly the Baseline
models don't do very well at that
because a chart is a much richer kind of
artifact than just an image right it's
got all this Rich structure so then we
said great let's look at a data table or
let's look at a scene graph or which is
just a fancy way of saying the SVG
associated with the chart and a priori
we would have thought well the scene
graph is maybe like a good in between
between the computational affordances of
a data table and capturing some of those
perceptual characteristics
turns out for the llms we train that
were all Transformer models they did
equivalently well on those two
representations and so one of the things
my group is working on right now is a
new way of representing visualizations
that more directly encode some of those
perceptual operations that are otherwise
currently implicit in a scene graph that
that you know grammar of Graphics
libraries like Vega light or ggplot
perform
but what's interesting in all of this to
me is that through these generative
models the goal has been how do we
impose a conceptual model onto them
right how do we bring some explicit
semantics and I think we're just
scratching the surface here as well
because I think the chart example uh
case is a really great one where a lot
of these representations of charts that
we've got right now the grammar of
graphics for instance were designed for
people to author right so we're really
good at figuring out how to design
programming languages domain specific
languages to emphasize the cognitive
characteristics that are important for
human authors things like you know the
cognitive dimensions of notation that
cares about you know how viscous is the
programming language how many premature
commitments is the programming language
enforce but I don't know what it means
to design a representation to be
suitable for an llm to operate over
right do we restructure the programming
language more fundamentally to make it
tractable for an llm Maybe
so in addition to generative models my
group has also been working with
predictive models and here I think the
bridging task is really not about
imposing a conceptual model but bridging
it or aligning it to the ones that we
already have and often the way that a
lot of this work happens is through the
lens of model interpretability so here
is a very popular set of techniques
called saliency Maps the idea behind
silencing Maps is they're trying to
depict the most important input features
for a particular outcome so in this case
you know this is an image the label
should be toy terrier and here's what a
variety of different kinds of silencing
methods believe to be you know the most
important pixels to produce that that
outcome now
I look at these visualizations and I go
well
you know is it telling me something
maybe right um and maybe the reason I
believe it's telling me something is
because I'm the one doing the perception
and interpretive tasks right like if I
look at some of those visualizations on
the bottom I go oh like it looks like
the dog snouter is really important to
the classification of a toy terrier or
the spots but it's not actually the
seancy method that is doing that
interpretation for me I'm the one
bringing meaning to those lit pixels
right and so as a result
if we think about that Gulf of
evaluation it's not the salency method
that's helping bridge that Gulf in any
way which is why sale and see maps for
now have been these tools that we just
use in a very ad hoc way that require a
lot of manual effort to make sense of
and so a question that my student Angie
bogust has been focused on is how do we
scaffold that semantic sense making
operation right providing some
additional structure to help sort of
scale it up to make it more reproducible
and things like that and and what she's
developed is these set of metrics that
are very analogous to ideas of precision
and recall but are operating at the
level of input features and
interpretability so in many data sets
right you've got some set of ground
truth human annotated features and what
shared interest is looking at is what is
the overlap between what a salesy method
considers as being important to the
classification and what the humans the
human annotators thought was important
and there's actually three different
ways that these overlaps can manifest
the first is a sort of ground truth
coverage which is very analogous to
ideas of recall right it's how much of
the ground truth does the model
incorporate in its prediction or or what
is the proportion of the ground truth
region that is covered by the salency
region and if we look at some examples
of low coverage on the top and High
coverage at the bottom we can see them
in the case of low ground truth coverage
is actually very little overlap right
between the ground truth the yellow
region and the Salient region in Orange
but I often find that it's actually the
High coverage regions that are more
interesting to analyze so if we compare
you know cases where the model was
correct on the right with the green
label and cases where the model was
incorrect with the red label we can see
in the case of correct High Ground truth
coverage there are instances where the
model relies not just on the object like
in this case with the cab but a lot of
contextual information as well to also
ultimately make that correct prediction
but on the flip side right with the
laptop the model is doing the same thing
but here it the context is actually
throwing it off right it's actually
confusing the model because it's
accounting for too much of that context
in its decision making
another kind of coverage is something we
call saliency coverage and this is more
akin to Precision right which is how
strictly is the model relying only on
ground truth features to make its sort
of prediction
um and again you know if we look at low
and high coverage and in the case of low
coverage we can see again pretty
disjoint
um sorts of of sets but in the case of
the High coverage regions we can see
that you know in the case of High
salency coverage it basically means that
the Salient regions are a strict subset
of the ground truth coverage but the
difference between a correct and
incorrect prediction is whether that
that that that subset was sufficient to
make the correct classification or not
right so in the case of the Maltese dog
it it did indeed only need to look at
the head to make that correct prediction
but in the case of the dalmatian it
probably should have accounted for more
of that dog's head or or some of the
other characteristics associated with
the dog by focusing only on the snout it
ended up sort of arriving at the
incorrect sort of classification and
finally the last metric is something
that is very familiar IOU the
intersection over the union this is sort
of the strictest shared interest metric
it's really measuring how aligned the
model's behavior is with human reasoning
so if you look at some examples again
you know low coverage at the top we can
see you know in incorrect cases totally
distinct disjoint sets again but in a
correct instance I actually find that
pretty interesting right low IOU
coverage but it got a correct
classification now one could say maybe
it got lucky but potentially what the
signal there is is that maybe all the
model needs is a tiny bit of a wheel
associated with a horse right to make
the prediction that is actually a horse
card and not just a horse right and on
the flip side with with High coverage
um you know Newfoundland great you know
total total alignment but in this case
right incorrect class classification
even though there was High coverage this
might suggest you know genuinely
difficult to classify images right even
for people because if I look at that a
pickup truck seems a totally reasonable
guest to have made about the image I
don't know that I've got enough sort of
visual information there to call that a
snowplow
so shared interest basically gives us a
mechanism to start to scaffold and
structure or bridge that semantic
distance right people no longer
necessarily need to manually start to
analyze these things
um and in fact you know we analyzed lots
of different models across you know both
vision and natural language and found
the different combinations of these
shared interest metrics along with
figuring out whether the prediction was
correct or not actually surfaced eight
kinds of repeating patterns in Model
Behavior so we can see human aligned and
some of these others we we also looked
at earlier right context confusion
context dependent and so forth and all
of these give us sort of semantics that
we can start to play around with through
different articulations so one
articulation of these semantics might be
a very traditional visual analytics
interface right where I've got all the
different kinds of of images that I care
about this is a system we built to help
a board-certified dermatologist make
sense of this melanoma detection model
and you've got you know query widgets on
the top to sort and filter you can use
you know these histograms of the shared
interest metrics to really drill into
the data but what was maybe most
interesting was what the dermatologist
said when they started to analyze that
that recurring pattern of context
dependent
cases so in particular when they switch
to these context dependent cases the the
dermatologist started to wonder if the
model is seeing something we are not
truly appreciating in the clinical image
maybe there are subtle changes we don't
yet understand that the model does right
at the boundaries of the skin Legion and
and things like that
um and so you know to me this is
alluding to the fact of well can we as
domain experts learn something about our
problem domain based on how it is models
are operating and I think we see this
more clearly in another articulation of
shared interest semantics here what
we're doing is basically using shared
interest to interactively probe or query
that latent space so we're brushing and
using that brushed region as ground
truth and then calculating the IOU
coverage to figure out what are all the
classes that maximize IOU coverage for
that brush ground truth so we can see if
I brush overhand a lot of the the
classes that get returned are things
that are often associated with hands
like laptops and Cleavers and
interestingly enough hen so I guess a
lot of the images in the imagenet uh you
know data data set have people holding
hens right which is I guess kind of
interesting
but more maybe profoundly is we could
ask a question like what is the essence
of a dog right what is the minimal
amount of region that I would need to
brush for the model to still be
convinced that what it is classifying is
a dog so I could start with the whole
dog and then brush just on its head and
and sure you know querying with shared
interest still returns you know dog
classes but then I could use a smaller
brush and brush just on the nose
and it still returns you know German
Shepherd and sheepdog and Tibetan
terrier and things like that so it seems
like according to the model all it
really needs to know about
um you know an object
um in the image is the sort of shape of
its nose or something associated with
its nose to be able to classify whether
it is or is not a dog and this seems
like a really sort of toy example but it
reflects some of the things that real
world scientists are doing so in
particular
um you know there's a a researcher at
the University of Washington Julia
Parish that runs this Grand crowdsourced
data collection project around seabird
deaths and the way they train their
participants to figure out how to do
bird classification is by asking them to
measure you know the bird beaks and the
bird feet and things like that and so I
think it's really interesting that we're
seeing maybe some of those sorts of
representations creep up in how a model
is is making its decision Visions as
well and and so where I want to end is
sort of being most speculative and where
I think uh you know there's scope for
for HCI to sort of grow and so you know
we looked at generative models and
imposing a conceptual model on them we
looked at predictive models where the
idea was to align conceptual models
um but what I think you know we're
hearing from that dermatologist we're
seeing in that last case study with
shared interest is the potential to use
machine learning models to basically
discover new representations of
particular problem domains right and you
know again at my most speculative I
don't know what I would call these but I
would maybe call them abstraction models
right where the goal of these models is
not to produce some particular outcome
that I care about but to maximize what
are the different ways of representing
the world right what are all the diverse
abstractions that we could learn about a
problem domain like classifying dogs or
classifying sea birds or things like
that and I think this is a really
interesting opportunity to use machine
learning to essentially Advance our
understanding Advance our science but I
want to be careful here because we've
already seen you know through this talk
but also in the broader discourse how
generative and predictive models can
sort of Muddy that that Gulf of
evaluation right lots of people are
starting to anthropomorphize these
models you know some people think these
models are representing general
intelligence or conscience or things
like that and there's a potential with
you know these abstraction models to
make this problem worse by mudiating
muddying the question of well how do we
know what we know right like what counts
as evidence
is it evidence because you know the
model has learned that representation
and how do we validate what that
evidence is in the case of
representations that are designed or
interpreted or theorized by people we
know how to consider that to be evidence
right but I don't know what it means for
a learned representation to count as
evidence and as all sorts of problems in
machine learning this is not necessarily
a problem that is unique to machine
learning so here are three
visualizations that were used to discuss
the covid-19 pandemic right at the the
the peak of the first wave in the summer
of 2020
and I'm curious if anything pops out at
you
like any reason you know to be curious
or suspect of of these visualizations
right like no right probably not like
these seem pretty legitimate right like
our world and data very legitimate data
source right um and if you look at look
at some of these two other
visualizations you might go you know
what actually the one on the right that
looks like something in maybe a policy
briefing or something right it looks
very sophisticated lots of good
annotation
um you know uh uh a a style and
aesthetic that looks very sort of
sophisticated
um but you may be catching what I'm
alluding to which is the fact that all
three visualizations were used by people
on social media to advance the argument
that
um you know our response to covid was
overblown not that kovid was a hoax but
that our reaction to it was was way too
extreme that kovid wasn't as serious uh
an issue as it might initially seem and
I want to be really careful about what
I'm what I'm doing here um with these
charts because certainly some of the
people that were just Distributing this
were bad actors who were ideologically
motivated but through a very long
laborious ethnography ethnographic
process that we conducted spending six
months on five different Facebook groups
we found that a lot of people who were
producing visualizations like that were
actually displaying many Hallmarks of
Citizen data science so there were
really many of them filling gaps in in
information sort of collection because
they were situated in rural parts of the
country where you know there wasn't a
lot of good data collections so many
members of these groups were hosting you
know webcasts live seminars of how to
download data from the government
website how to clean it in Excel how to
visualize it and things like that and
and most surprisingly to us many of them
were engaged in discussion that looked
like peer review right they were
critically assessing data sources
discussing metrics making Arguments for
which metrics were were better or not
but all of this was sort of inflected
through a sort of frustration with
mainstream institutions and maybe even
distrust of those institutions as well
right but ultimately what these groups
cared about was bolstering a sense of
social unity and Civic engagement right
so this quote I I find particularly sort
of reflective of that sense of you know
it's incumbent on all of us to hold our
elected officials to account so that
they make better decisions through data
right I'm speaking to you as a neighbor
as a Mama Bear right so this is not some
sort of ideologically motivated
individual who is who is you know trying
to be a bad actor this is just an
Engaged member of the citizenry and
similarly you know oftentimes they were
actually more sophisticated than
scientists can be so many of these
members were very reflexive about their
own data analysis data Gathering process
right so someone says you know I've
never claimed to have no bias right I'm
human of course I'm biased here are my
biases whereas in science often we like
to portray ourselves as being very
objective you know Arbiters of Truth and
so in many ways you know what was
happening in these groups is is perhaps
more sophisticated
um then what was happening in science
and Public Health at the time but the
question is so what does this have to do
with sort of bridging semantic distances
and and abstraction models well I think
what was happening in in those groups
was you know they they they disagreed
with the definitions of some of these
metrics right they were living in rural
communities and so the metrics that
public health officials were using to to
you know Define the the state and scale
of the pandemic was not reflected in
their lived experience they were turning
around and well it didn't seem like
covid was an issue right and so our
colleagues in the humanities and social
sciences often advocate for adopting
what they call an interpretive
interpretivist lens right the idea the
knowledge is subjective it's socially
constructed and that it's composed of
many different diverse perspectives that
we have to figure out ways to synthesize
together and while that idea has been
adopted in pockets of visualization and
HCI and CS so far I think it's largely
been on the qualitative side because if
we think about how to do computation we
have to you know we're forced into
making decisions about the world and how
to represent that world and
computational data structures and what I
think abstraction models allow us to do
is start to push but you know push that
boundary a little bit right rather than
being focused on developing a model that
produces a single best outcome we might
instead be looking to World in which we
are training sort of ecosystems of
abstraction models where we're forcing
them to learn really different
representations of the world or of a
problem domain and then leaving it up to
people to figure out how to synthesize
between those learned representations
for you know some particular policy goal
or or you know um uh uh thing that they
want to optimize for so with that I'm
I'm happy to take questions about any of
what I talked about thank you very much
all right
we've got some kinds of questions
comments
I want to start off about the uh like
comparing sailing seam labs to ground
trip
so humans are really not
accurate sometimes when you ask them
like what is the important thing this
image that made me make this decision so
do you think the results would be
different if you used like eye fixations
in that comparison that's a interesting
question um we we I haven't can we
haven't considered eye fixations
um uh for the for the sales team map
work but certainly I I think your your
intuition is right in the sense that you
know the current way that we've modeled
you know shared interest is pretty
brittle right it's operating at the the
level of abstraction of like pixels in
an image and how meaningful are pixels
really
um and so what Angie is working on right
now is a way to to raise the level of
abstraction that shared interest is
working on so in many of these domains
like you know imagenet
um the the the tasks that we're asking
models to do the labeling task actually
inherits from a much richer Knowledge
Graph or taxonomy or hierarchy or things
like that but right now at least you
know there's a little bit of work in
hierarchical learning but most of the
predictive models are just learning at
the finest level of detail right so
we're throwing away all that rich
information that might be really
relevant to how a person is making a
decision so maybe what I care about is
not whether it's a Chihuahua or a golden
retriever retriever I might care is it a
dog or really sometimes is it just an
object right and so what does it look
like to do shared interest in more
meaningful abstraction space rather than
pixels is something we're working on
yeah great question thanks yeah well
thank you for great talk Arvin so going
back to Jupiter notebooks and chat GPT
uh you talked about how right chat gbt
can shell out to some of these nice
plugins like for Excel or whatever to
try and help people do natural language
data science and and that they're this
articulatory distance due to the
difficulty of learning an API but
conversely you could say tools like
copilot are sort of the parallel to
overcoming that articulatory Distance by
almost
sense what is the same interface
expressing a natural language but just
during a code comment and then getting
back um code right but just I guess the
only difference is its code you can see
as opposed to code that's running in
some back end that you don't see and I'm
curious if you think there's sort of a
synthesis of these two polls an
interface that that can take the Best of
Both Worlds and offers conversation but
still provides access to the code or
encourages people to understand the
annoying representations just a few yeah
absolutely I um you know I I thought
really hard about you know which of
those examples I wanted to to use as the
kind of foil to be to so I did very
seriously consider a co-pilot um and and
I I sort of agree with your analysis
that it's it's I think a much better
example of how to integrate
um you know the capacity of these llms
and and I think there's you know
opportunity to push that even further
where uh you know what I would often
want is really targeted mechanisms to
introduce ambiguity right uh right now
the little that I've used co-pilot it's
it's almost at the level of well it's
going to produce the
you know the whole function the whole
whatever
um and often what I want is it to be the
sort of parallel prototyper for me right
I want to introduce say a hole in my
program and then go I don't know that I
want that hole to be filled in with just
one specific you know outcome but I want
it to produce like the whole space and
for me to go well I want a little bit of
this and a little bit of that and so on
and so forth
um so yeah I uh you know I totally agree
with there being some really interesting
medium of of these things cool yeah I
like that idea
yeah hey really exciting talk um I'm
wondering uh towards your kind of vision
for these abstraction models I'm
wondering like obviously
kind of from a you know human computer
interaction perspective we know like
representation matters so much right
like isomorphs of representation very
much change how people can uh approach a
problem or understand it but I guess the
the ways in which they very and the
benefits of these different
representations are tied very much to
human cognition and perception and I'm
wondering you know in some of the
examples you're showing and a lot of
work in machine learning we're sort of
training Things based upon the output
yeah and I'm wondering like you know are
there ways that we can get at more of
how people are thinking versus just how
they output yeah and how do we get there
yeah I love this question
um and uh the reason I love it is is
also the reason I love sort of that
Hutchins at all description of direct
manipulation right I find the terms that
they use there particularly these two's
distances really evocative terms because
to me a distance is something that I
would want to measure right right but so
far at least as far as I know those
terms have largely been descriptive
right as you saw in my talk like I use
them to be very analytic but I'm not
able to be generative with them in in
you know a very systematic way so
certainly a lot of um the work that uh
my group is trying to do right now is in
visualization you know there's a lot of
work that that we've inherited in in
methods from sort of vision signs so we
run these studies of human perception
um and increasingly the field is
starting to get to well how do we start
to measure cognition right can we model
sort of a decision-making task and and
start to you know operationalize that
through experimental design
um and so we're starting to push in some
of those directions as well but scope 2
sort of you know interaction in a
Jupiter notebook but then starting to
see you know the impact that interaction
has on sort of the downstream analyzes
people would do and then see if that
actually Maps to you know their goals or
things like that absolutely yeah
so I'm curious about the just continue
on this line of perception up through
cognition yeah you know going back to
the sort of like
pretend Cleveland McGill kind of stuff
right the
automatic processing was very key to the
design of visualizations especially
early on that the the notion was that my
encodings were supposed to map on to
almost like system one uh interpretation
right like when I see the scatter plot
in the encoding distance in the
following way I'm gonna I'm gonna draw
the correct conclusion and it's
interesting to me that sort of through
the
through the Transformations you've
started to pursue we're not trying to
like encode those into a similar
a a similar mapping for audio but
instead directly doing the cognition on
behalf yeah of of the individual yeah
and I those seem like orthogonal
directions one could go right I'm
curious how we find the right point in
the design space yeah yeah I think this
is a fantastic question so the the the
way my group is starting to think about
this um of like how do we find the sort
of right balance of who is doing the
perception who is doing the
interpretation is starting to consider
some of these modalities in concert to
better understand what the relative
affordances of these modalities are so
in particular um Jonathan who you saw in
the demos is is leading some really
really cool work right now around
um what if I'm sort of specifying the
visual the audio the sort of sonified
audio and the textual audio side by side
and then I'm playing them sort of
simultaneously through do I want you
know there to be sort of perceptual
redundancy where the sonification is is
sort of of emphasizing what is you know
described in the text or do I want these
modalities to be complementary
um and uh you know sort of TBD but but I
think there's some really exciting sort
of questions for for us to sort of dig
into right space are there similar
pre-attentive principles for audio there
must be
as far as I know so I'm you know we're
just starting to look in the sort of
sonification literature yeah as far as
we can tell sound is a very very
different perceptual sense
um than vision and so even the sort of
you know uh basic sort of visual
encoding Paradigm where I take a data
field I map it to you know position
color size that breaks down very rapidly
for audio so oftentimes really all that
people are able to sort of
um you know detect differences in or
sort of pitch and loudness and even then
our Fidelity at that is is very very low
and so there might be some pre-attentive
characteristics
um we're certainly looking at some early
work in HCI I think Stephen Brewster
um had done around sort of ear cons you
know discrete sort of representations of
of icons but through audio and things
like that so there may be some of that
there but at least so far we're so early
in our own work that that we don't know
interesting yeah okay thank you yeah
yeah I think we're about at times so
maybe well if you have additional
questions please mob him after the talk
uh thank you Arvin for joining us thank
you very much